dave our question comes from
deidra in tennessee my husband and i had
sixteen thousand dollars in student
loans when
he graduated two years ago and now we
only have eight thousand dollars left i
love it
uh we have been paying even during the
moratorium to pay down the principal
so we are ahead of payments by quite a
bit
awesome we are reading in the news that
congress might write off ten thousand
dollars of
everyone's student loan debt should we
keep paying to take advantage of the no
interest at this time or stop paying and
wait to see
uh what they will do if you're going to
wait to see
if the congress is going to do something
you are going to be disappointed
i'm not saying 100 guarantee it won't
happen but here's the thing
uh in my history i've never seen it so
if i was in your shoes i'm paying
it off i'm not stopping i'm not waiting
for the congress
you know if you wait on washington to
fix your life your life's always going
to suck
this is a good rule so i don't know
what's going to happen with this i mean
um i have no idea there's no way of
knowing i was pretty sure
a few months ago but the political
climate has shifted
and uh the power structure has shifted
and so
it's possible that they run this through
i don't know
i never dreamed i would see it in my
lifetime but i've seen a whole lot of
stuff in my lifetime i never dreamed i
would see
my life right so um i
i i don't
um yeah i if i were in your shears i
agree i
because i'm not gonna wait to fix my
life on
washington to save me right and so it's
um
it's just a bad plan and again they may
turn around by the end of summer and you
may go i hate dave ramsey
just cost me 10 grand um but and i hate
anthony o'neil
oh yeah you have to be on the same list
i mean this is real i mean
that's this is my suggestion well i was
agreeing with you
okay either way pay it off dude yeah
listen folks i'm
i'm always going to tell you pay off
your loans yeah all right we're just
always going to tell you
take you have to control the
controllables let me tell you what you
can't control
congress you can't control the president
and you can what you can control is
paying off the loan so control the
controllables and build you a life and
that's your best plan so now let me ask
you this question dave i think i know
your answer but it's fair to ask it so
what if they just say you know what
since there's no interest what if i just
put that money to the side for the next
four months while there is no interest
i'm just not going to try to game the
system right gotcha
every time people try to game stuff is
when they get screwed
and it's when it doesn't work out for
them and so what let me tell you what
would happen
some percentage of the time we throw ten
thousand dollars in an account
we're sitting around waiting we really
hadn't been aggressive by paying off
student loan
we let our foot off the gas we're not
really budgeting tight
and man i sure did need that bass boat
go buy the bass boat congress says you
know what we can't get that student loan
thing through
and you're still sitting there staring
at a dad gum
paid for bass boat right with your money
you should have used to pay off your
student loan
this is what happens then you end up in
coaching one of our coaching offices
somewhere
and people are going you did what and
you're going yeah i know i was so stupid
and we all have these moments where we
did something but it always comes around
trying to scam trying to scheme trying
to
trying to run the system somehow i'm
going to run the system i'm going to
beat the system and don't beat the
system
pay off your debt yeah just don't you
know there's no shortcut to any place
that's worth going